the pride of utep football now uh
running the football for the green bay
packers as the lead back he has earned
that right to be called that
and um yes there's another aaron on the
uh
on the green bay packers who is of
crucial importance
the running back of the green bay
packers aaron jones back here on the
show how are you sir
how you doing thank you for having me
again always aaron now aaron
uh this is uh somewhat of a new audience
potentially here on this show because
we're
we're on nbcsn now and now we're on the
new streamer peacock so
let's uh let's uh reset if you will for
our new audience
um which which show of national radio
and television had you on in studio when
no one else did aaron what show was that
what show would what what would be the
name of that show would it be called the
rich eisen show
aaron the rich arjun show when we did
the uh
we did the 40 outside yes we did we was
watching people do the 40. we were
watching people do the 40. i think you
made them right
i think you were making them nervous
aaron i'll be honest with you because i
certainly wasn't
i'll tell you that but you were here you
were
here and so so which show was pretty
much uh
on to you as a force in the national
football league before any other show
coast to coast uh the retirement show uh
day one before i was even
um really getting any love from anybody
else you've been rocking with me so i
really appreciate that and right
back at you aaron jones what is your
mindset
going into 2020 walk me through your
list of goals
sir please uh
just to be be more explosive uh be more
productive
and bring the title back to title town i
think that's our whole team's goal we we
fell
just short last year in the nfc
championship and we felt like we were
close
we got an ugly taste in our mouth so we
just want to get back there and
bring the title back home and bringing
that title back home
what about your goals personally though
i mean you're a team player there is no
i
and aaron or jones i understand that but
what what what is
your personal statistical potential
goals what have you written down for
yourself
have you written anything i haven't
written anything down yet but i
want to have a better year than i did
last year and like i said be more
productive finish off those
um five five six seven yard runs and
turn those into big runs and
just be a consistent home run hitter for
my team and your conversations with
aaron rodgers what are they about
when you have them uh they're about
everything uh
how we can improve what he wants me to
do on
certain plays or certain routes on a
little screen
if it's a little screen pass did i never
did i navigate it right or
um and then just like communication from
the o-line uh
and what they're doing on certain plays
and then um just life
outside of football as well he's a great
great leader true leader he cares about
everybody on this team
and what are you better at now than you
were at maybe when you were here
personally um as a rising star in this
league trying to make your mark what are
you better at
uh i would say uh being being a receiver
i feel like i've improved on that
tremendously since i've been there and
coached the floor has allowed me to
showcase that and going to continue to
work on that
well it's interesting that you would say
that you're a better receiver uh i think
packers fans just jumped off their couch
wherever they're looking saying that's
good to know since
um that was kind of not hit in the draft
in 2020
uh aaron uh where were you draft night
and draft weekend uh-huh i was in el
paso texas
okay at my parents house all right uh
you weren't the only erin to have
somebody drafted at the uh position
during the draft is that correct aaron
jones uh correct
okay what'd you think of the drafting of
aj dylan now i understand you share the
same room as a
meeting room as him but uh what did that
say to you
aaron uh i mean a little shocking but
at the same time i know uh the nfl is a
business and they're bringing in guys
uh to compete every day um so
at the end of it i know um it's a
business so i mean he didn't choose
where he was going
right uh the packers chose him so i
can't hold nothing against him i'm just
here to help him grow as a player
um and help this football team did it
piss you off aaron
let's be honest let's talk did it piss
you off just even for a slight bit
oh no uh it didn't it didn't piss me off
it's just
kind of caught by a surprise but and
then again i've been uh
towed for so long it's a business and
you see it year after year
well sure i guess then let me put it
this way has it lit a fire under you
did it light even more uh yes sir
you could you could definitely say that
okay now matt laflore at this point last
year
was a rookie coach and you were just
learning system
that um that he was bringing in
what what level of comfort comfort do
you have now
in this system and how will that be
manifesting itself on the field for you
and your teammates now that you've got a
year in
with him uh i think we all feel a lot
more comfortable uh we
we know the ins and outs now before we
were last year we were just we were
learning it
and running it as we go um we really
didn't
understand the true details and um what
the power of the play was and
why we were running it but now this year
we've had this whole offseason um
luckily we had zoom our coaches did a
good job on there
and when we got back into the facility
and just
kind of breaking down the playbook
taking a deep dive into it and
understanding why we're doing what we're
doing and on certain plays
what we're trying to accomplish and um i
think
i think you'll see a lot of guys playing
a lot faster um
playing more comfortable we're not
you're not going out there having to
think about
what you're doing when the play is
called you hear it and you can just go
and
go and play and react well i mean play
and react it sounds like you know
you're not the only aaron who does lose
excels at playing
and reacting i mean it this this uh
opportunity with you and rogers and
devonte adams and i know how much has
been made and even i
earlier made reference to the to the
receiving corps
what does a receiving corps think of
when when they hear
somebody like me or anybody else talk
about
the lack of receivers and name receivers
for your team
they must hear that aaron uh
they just kind of smile uh i mean i
think i think they kind of like the
position they're in where
people are kind of doubting them and um
thinking that there's
nobody else in that room but we have
some legit guys and
mvs and uh lazard and jake comro
we have guys who can go out there and
can play some real ball and
uh i think those guys did a good job
last year and uh
they pop on when you cut on the tape
they pop out a bit and
making making plays for us so i'm
excited
me too i think they they have another
year in this offense and they can
they they've gotten a chance to grow
they've had all season they've gotten a
chance to grow
i'm excited for you you are a match-up
nightmare
for so many teams aaron i saw it the
first minute you took the field
and you got a quarterback who knows
exactly where to put you in that
position
and he's it's a team that last year
nobody gave credit for almost being the
one seed
i kind of feel like you're people aren't
paying attention to you again aaron
would you agree with that assessment
uh i definitely think think that or
if not that then they think we're going
to take a step back but uh
i mean our those guys here are hungry we
know how close we were
and we want we want that super ball okay
who was your guy growing up i might have
asked you that before but i forgot
who's the guy that you i emulated
growing up baron
i liked i liked emma smith uh jamal
charles
uh chris johnson marshall faulk um percy
harvin
um guys like that okay have you ever
spoken any of them have you ever
chatted with anybody i did get a chance
to meet uh emma smith uh
this was last offseason not this past
one but the one before that
and uh just getting a chance to talk to
him was uh something special uh
i almost cried i i called my mom right
away
and you'll never guess who i talked to
and i even got i
even got a picture with uh him as well
him and barry sanders and jim brown
got a picture with all three of those
guys but uh i was just
i was just in shock because for so long
and ms smith was my favorite running
back growing up in
to finally get a chance to meet him and
talk to him and then see how
down the earth and cool and he watched
he was like he watched my games he could
tell me about myself
i think i think that was amazing aaron
you know out of all and everyone else
you know i can
i can hook you up with marshall easily
would that be
something you'd want i've actually i
actually talked to marshall too so it
makes sense
i'm i'm supposed to be coming on his uh
his drug free uh podcast
pretty soon but i got i got the chance
to talk to him i want to say last week
or the week before that
and just you could tell he he cares
about
the current players and
really the running backs as a whole um
just he
he's an open book of knowledge and he
accept the phone call and he he just
he just wants to give you share all his
knowledge with you to make you a better
player makes total sense
i really i really appreciate marshall
for that as well
he is without a doubt and chris brockman
who was across the uh row for me you
were his segment producer on nfl game
day morning for two years correct chris
correct
correct uh uh we were both a test uh
smartest
guy uh maybe one of the smartest guys
we've ever met
but in terms of football and in terms of
uh
common sense just in terms of sense
maybe the greatest combination of brains
and talent
that's ever put on uh i thought i knew a
lot about football oh please then i got
to work with marshall i know and he
so maybe he's downloaded to you
the fact that you at your position if
you know
the route that everybody's running on
the field and know
what the quarterback is thinking pre and
post snap that would help you as a
running back that's exactly what
marshall did
oh definitely and uh i mean he talked to
me a little bit about that and
so i'm taking an even deeper dive into
the playbook and just learning what
everybody on the field is doing like you
said not just
my position or my route that's
absolutely right all right aaron jones
well
you go crush it you go crush it i'll be
looking i'll be rooting as always
big time and i appreciate you taking the
time
yes sir thank you and thank you for
always rocking with me no always and by
the way
i don't know if you're aware ever you
know since you've been here i've gotten
faster at the 40s so you inspired me as
well
yeah yes sir let's keep let's keep
working on it yeah exactly you know i'm
i'm uh
five nine what was i for this year five
nine eight
something like that you were sub six i
was sub six um
and i'm just you know like that fine
wine and i think part of it is just
knowing you and um
being inspired by you being here for my
40 yard dash a couple years ago on this
campus
oh yes sir i hope i can be there for the
one this year coming up excellent well
you take care of yourself aaron stay
healthy stay safe hope this season goes
as well as you'd like
yes sir thank you and thank you for
having me right back at you right back
at you that's aaron jones the green bay
packers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here